[Music]
on this Saturday night an indigenous man
shot and killed by RCMP why the Mounties
in New Brunswick's say they had no
choice they were confronted by a man who
had knives and why a police watchdog
from another province is now
investigating its New Brunswick's second
police involved death of an indigenous
person this month how can we ever trust
any police force tonight the memorial
March for Chantal more plus the backlash
facing Donald Trump as he tries to rally
support for his reelection campaign and
remembering the rapture of the Raptors
victory one year ago
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin in New Brunswick where for
the second time this month police have
shot and killed an indigenous person it
started last night when RCMP responded
to a call about a disturbed person near
the city of near me sheep northeast of
Fredericton tonight Quebec police
watchdog is investigating what led to
the man's death globals Callum Smith has
the story
it's just heartbreaking family members
are searching for answers after New
Brunswick RCMP fatally shot an
indigenous man Friday night police say
they were called to this home in the
community of boom Road about half hour
from ear mushy for a report of an
unwanted person when members arrived on
scene they were confronted by a man who
had knives and lunged at the members
energy weapon was deployed and it was
unsuccessful and in our scene team
member member discharged a firearm 48
year-old Rodney Levi was taken to
hospital where he later died the family
says he had mental health and drug
addiction concerns with crystal meth but
wasn't able to get treatment if he would
have got the help that he needed
maybe this we wouldn't be here today
wouldn't be Rodney would have been
scared because he thought the police
were really wanting to kill him he told
several people that day the police are
going to kill me which was not not
that's not what was happening he just
his drug-induced psychosis that's what
he thought and felt in a hundred percent
believed family says he was going to
visit a local pastor to help him heal
but that's someone at the home who might
not have known him may have called the
police
Levi's niece says he loved her kids and
was a pleasure to be around it's a sin
because he's the most beautiful person
you could ever meet he was so kind
gentle he loved he was you just loved
everybody he was most generous being
I've ever met
but the second fatal police involved
shooting of an indigenous person in New
Brunswick and
last two weeks as a pain this family
can't comprehend leaving them searching
for answers as Quebec scalise watchdog
investigates RCMP x' actions Calum Smith
Global News the government in New
Brunswick has launched a coroner's
inquest into the death of Chantal Moore
the indigenous woman was shot and killed
by police in New Brunswick who were
asked to check in on her well-being
tonight there are calls for a bigger
review hundreds of people including her
family gathered for healing marches
today demanding a full public inquiry
into the provinces policing and justice
system as Silas Brown reports today's
walk was mostly silent but the message
was loud they walked in silence
through the streets of the Madawaska
Maliseet first nation in the Edmundston
slowly to try and heal the pain caused
by loss summers as if our ancestors from
below that we've buried were lifting us
up to tell us not to give up and that's
what was going through my mind at the
head
Martha Martin whose daughter Chantel
Moore was shot and killed by Edmundston
police during a wellness check on June
4th we shouldn't have to be afraid of
having that wellness call you know the
message today is you know we're gonna
come together as one and and that's
really important
Martin was joined by a dozen family
members who came from British Columbia
for Moore's Funeral the walk ended in
Edmundston Town Square where family
spoke to the crowd we've been hurt many
times how can we ever trust any police
force why should we even answer the door
for a wellness check how more leaves
behind a young daughter her great aunt
Nora Martin spoke at the end of the walk
about how indigenous children shouldn't
have to grow up without mothers
yesterday we were invited to the topi
community and on our way there she kept
talking about her mother
she said I don't want to die like my
mother in the wake of Moore's death
calls for an inquiry into systemic
racism in New Brunswick have grown
louder but Saturday's walk was about
healing and to allow the family a chance
to cry once again for justice for their
daughter Silas Brown Global News
Edmundston New Brunswick there have been
several violent confrontations involving
indigenous Canadians and police this
week on the West block Mercedes
Stevenson opens up a dialogue with some
prominent advocates for Canada's First
Nations communities Mercedes Robin in
recent days there has been a change in
the conversations that many Canadians
are having as a country we're talking
about systemic racism what it means
where it is found and the negative
impact it has on our society as well as
how we can address it and move forward
Cindy
stocke is a very well-known and
respected advocate for indigenous
children I asked her to explain what
exactly we're talking about when people
refer to systemic racism in Canada well
what's the stomach racism means to me is
when treating people differently because
of a particular trait becomes normalized
in society and in some ways even made
benevolent you think about residential
schools the removal of First Nations
maintaining you eat children for their
families because the assumption was it
was better for the kids because these
parents could take care of them and even
now we have the federal government who
at the same time while they're
admonishing systemic racism in police
forces and other institutions are
actually perpetrating racial
discrimination against a hundred and
sixty-five thousand children that's not
a matter of opinion it's a matter of
court order and as recently as September
of 2019
they were found that that discrimination
was resulting in unnecessary family
separations and the deaths of some
children so they can stand there and say
that they're against it while they
perpetrated at the same time systemic
racism in the RCMP has been a
controversial subject over the past week
since a video emerged of the arrest of
chief Allen Adham in Alberta over an
expired license plate our CMP
commissioner Brenda lucky said she is
struggling to understand the term
systemic racism but she did believe
unconscious bias exists in the force
I asked national chief Perry bellegarde
what he thought of the commissioner's
comments I recall a few years back
former commissioner Bob Paulson came to
our chiefs in assembly and clearly
stated he had the courage he had the
courage in front of the Chiefs of Canada
to say there is racism the RCMP and we
need to deal with it and need to fix it
he wanted to get the racists out of the
RCMP so that was four or five years back
I don't believe that it has been fixed
at all so we have a lot of work to do
now and I go back to my earlier point
it's there we don't need to question
whether or not there is racism or
systemic racism or the excessive use of
force it's there let's put our energy
how do we fix it to make sure that our
people don't get hurt or killed at the
hands of the RCMP anymore we'll have
more on the show about racism Inc
the concern about systemic racism and
policing and in particular the RCMP and
what needs to change in our country
going forward Robin
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa and you can
see the extended interviews on the West
block with Mercedes Stevenson tomorrow
some breaking news tonight
Atlantis police chief has resigned after
members of her police force fatally shot
a black man Friday night 27 old Rashard
Brooks was sleeping in a vehicle in a
Wendy's parking lot when police tried to
arrest him a struggle ensued and he
tried to run away
he was then shot Atlanta's mayor who
announced the news late today says she
does not believe this shooting was a
justified use of deadly force while
there may be debate as to whether this
was an appropriate use of deadly force I
firmly believe that there is a clear
distinction between what you can do and
what you should do one of the officers
reportedly pulled out a Taser during the
struggle which the man ended up taking
and tried to fire at officers before he
was shot as he fled he was taken to a
hospital where he died after surgery the
two officers involved have been removed
from duty pending a further
investigation anti-racism rallies are
taking place around the world again this
weekend in London police formed barriers
between supporters of black lives matter
and far-right protesters in Trafalgar
Square in the middle of it flares and
smoke bombs were tossed into the crowd
it was a similar scene in Paris where
anti-racism protesters clashed with
counter demonstrators at one point a
small group of far-right activists
climbed a building and unfurled a giant
banner that read white lives matter the
US president is bowing to public
pressure and rescheduling a campaign
rally that was set for Juneteenth that's
the day to commemorate the end of
slavery in America but the criticism
wasn't enough to force Trump to
reschedule a controversial speech today
Jennifer Johnson explains
with cadet social distancing u.s.
president Donald Trump addressed more
than a thousand graduates of West Point
Military Academy in New York I want to
take this opportunity to thank all
members of America's armed forces who
step forward to help battle the
invisible enemy the new virus that came
to our shores from a distant land called
China Trump's speech comes during a
contentious time in his relationship
with military leaders a number of them
including defense secretary mark Esper
and Joint Chiefs chairman general mark
Milley have accused the president of
politicizing the military when he
suggested using soldiers against
protesters in the wake of George Floyd's
death but he did not address that
meanwhile the president is set to go
back on the campaign trail next week
late Friday he reversed course changing
the date of his campaign kickoff rally
in Tulsa from June 19th June 20th Tulsa
has a long history of racial tensions
and the 19th is known as Juneteenth when
African Americans mark the end of
slavery think about it as a celebration
the president has several upcoming
rallies as cases of copán 19 continue to
rise in at least 14 states we've already
uncorked indeed we got our wish which
was to end the home quarantine orders
and now we're seeing people treat that
as if kovat 19 is no longer an issue and
that's far from the fact the CDC
continues to encourage people to avoid
large gatherings and wear a mask
something many Trump supporters failed
to do at a packed Church in Dallas
Thursday drawing criticism I was angry
because that's our commander in chief
that's the person who's supposed to be
leading the effort to keep you alive in
the time code but with his job on the
and forced to take a three-month hiatus
the president is anxious to ignite his
supporters meanwhile his White House
coronavirus task force hasn't addressed
the American public for over seven weeks
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
after the United States Brazil now has
the second highest death toll from Cova
19 critics are calling out president
Shahir balsan ro for exacerbating the
health pandemic by reopening the country
too soon more than 41,000 people have
died from Kovan 19 in Brazil and there
are more than 800 and 28,000 cases in
the country a district in Beijing is
under a wartime emergency after a new
cluster of Cova 19 was traced back to
the largest meat and vegetable market in
the city center there are fears that may
fuel a second wave in China's densely
populated capital coming up the
controversial psychedelic treatments
making the medical comeback
- nan
in the 50s Canadian researchers were
considered world leaders in the use of
psychedelics to treat mental health
issues but in the 60s you couldn't
mention these drugs without thinking of
hippies today there's a second wave of
this controversial treatment and it's
showing promise mic delay reports it's
meant to mimic a sensory deprivation
tank blindfold headphones and as you sit
back in the zero-gravity chair the
psychedelic effects of ketamine take
hold in the 1960s recreational LSD
pioneer Timothy Leary spurred an entire
generation to embrace cultural change
through psychedelics and while the
counterculture movement got high
the US and Canadian governments weren't
feeling the same buzz all research into
the clinical benefits of psychedelics
ceased and the drugs went further
underground
that is until recent years when
scientists began looking for
alternatives to antidepressants the need
exists because there are so many people
struggling with depression and anxiety
and other mental health conditions
MDMA known on the street as ecstasy or
Molly has shown promise in treating PTSD
as have clinical trials looking at
psilocybin or magic mushrooms to treat
depression
the only psychedelic legal for medicinal
use in Canada ketamine is the primary
drug being used at Toronto's field trip
the first psychedelic enhanced therapy
clinic in Canada and that patients for
whom antidepressants have stopped
working
unlike pills like prozac which are taken
daily the psychedelic model involves
multiple sessions where patients are
dosed and then treated the current model
is you know we're gonna give you
pharmaceuticals they're going to numb
your experiences so we're gonna just
numb your sadness we're going to also
simultaneously numb your joy and what
we're trying to do is rewire the brain
in a healthy way and you need a
therapist guiding you to do that
Canadians are among the highest
consumers of antidepressants in the
world trailing only the US Iceland and
Australia but antidepressants because of
their side effects are as controversial
as they are popular which in turn has
fuelled interest in largely unproven
psychedelics we have almost no long-term
research so just because you feel an
incredible you know right after a trip
or even a week after a trip doesn't tell
us anything about what's gonna happen to
you in six months a year or longer
Canadian researchers in the 50s were
digging for those answers almost seven
decades later the one in ten Canadians
who rely on antidepressants are hoping
today's doctors find what they were
looking for microlight Global News
Toronto
still ahead wearing the badge as a black
woman
Stacy Clark has been a member of the
Toronto Police Service for more than two
decades she's one of only five black
female police inspectors in all of
Canada and as Karen Lieberman explains
she has a unique perspective on what's
happening in the world right now and a
warning this story contains disturbing
footage I was angry I was frustrated all
at the same time because I really in
that moment I heard the cried for his
mother I heard the I can't breathe
22 years of policing of building
partnerships to try and bridge the gap
between the black community and Toronto
Police Service of rising through the
ranks to become one of five black female
inspectors in Canada and then the cries
heard around the world by George Floyd
you know you're trying so hard to
instill a certain trust and then in nine
minutes god sparking a movement
demanding change I recognize that the
statements that were being made were
statements at my uniform and the system
and some of the systemic racism that
exists
inspector Stacey Clarke balances the
duties of the police uniform with those
of a proud member of the black community
on top of that she's raising a daughter
and a son with whom she has very candid
conversations how do you talk to a
police officer what do you say to a
police officer it just sits second
nature for him he's like 11 you know
it's really it's second nature for him
and it's what money does I have to just
prepare them how to handle it that ended
up being my answer all week I have to
prepare them for how to handle it
because I know they will have to
there is no denying she says that
systemic racism exists in this country
on many levels anti black racism Israel
systemic racism is real and it is here
and it is not just in policing
institutions it's in our education
institutions and quite frankly in our
health institutions Clark says despite
calls to defund the police she sees a
rule for law enforcement in Canada but
would like to see communities be a part
of recreating the systems that treat
people unfairly this can't be just a
black police officer to fix this this
can't be a black community to fix this
everyone has an equal partner in equal
role in this and this she says is how it
starts you do all that you can to be the
person that removes the knee off of
joyful isn't that you need to be that
person to remove that me Karen Lieberman
Global News Toronto up next Basketball
Diaries the game that made NBA history
in Canada
[Music]
muted celebrations mark the Queen's
official birthday in Britain but the
bans on large gatherings because of Cova
19 forced the Royals to break from
tradition instead of a large parade
known as the trooping the colour
soldiers gave a private performance it's
the first time Queen Elizabeth who
turned 94 in April has appeared in
public since Britain's locked down
remember the energy from the Toronto
Raptors NBA championship win well that
was one year ago and tonight global news
will air a special at 7 p.m. to relive
that magical moment the Raptors had a
shot at doing it all again this year but
the season stalled because of Koba 19
the NBA schedule starts again this
summer and as Anthony Bruno reports fans
are once again on the edge of their
seats 24 seasons in the making one big
trophy and one even bigger party it was
a victory for Canada fans gathering from
coast to coast celebrating the Raptors
first NBA championship everyone just
kind of emerged and everyone sort of
knew where to go and just seeing the
sort of energy on the streets and
everyone was celebrating honking horns
waving flags just sort of the vibe was
very good this is poetic
this is polenta you just got to watch it
happen the six and six we did this we
did this all my heart
forty four percent of the nation's
population tuned in for at least some of
the championship winning game it was a
defining moment for Canadian sports the
team's momentum continued into this
season despite the loss of star player
Kawhi Leonard the Raptors were sitting
in second place in the Eastern
Conference
when kovat 19 halted hopes for a repeat
they're still well-positioned to be
solid and it's it's a obviously
unfortunate that the season has been so
up in the air because they could have
beaten anyone in the playoffs hope has
reignited with news the NBA will return
this summer playing all games at Disney
World in Orlando the feeling will be
much different though there won't be
fans in the stands or outside packing
Jurassic Park like we saw one year ago
but after capturing the hearts of fans
across the country you can bet everyone
will be watching once again cheering on
the Raptors
as they attempt to defend their
championship as for another parade this
year well if the Raptors pull off the
repeat Canada is going to have to get
creative with its celebration this time
around
Anthony Bruno Global News Toronto and
that is global national for this
Saturday I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is a beautiful sunset in Bertie
Bay Newfoundland and Labrador thank you
for watching and we'll see you back here
tomorrow good night
[Music]
[Applause]
me